how does the road that you took to get
to London affect your confidence now
that you're here I'm a little more
confidence than in India I don't know
why since here for prayers is really
really strong well it's a question
connected to my last performance I guess
yeah it was it was up and down but
making making it to the finals is
something that I value a lot and like
say that I think I haven't played my
best to get here
still the result proves otherwise
Who am I to judge the mathematics well
to be firm I didn't play wind in all
classical tournaments right after the
thing filled cup I thought chances I
make it very dim turned out that I got
all the results I needed from Romania
and Calcutta even though it didn't seem
like it for the moment I've had a decent
result overall and of course I'm not
coming like a victim that's definitely
not that's what I'm doing so I'm here to
win it
I cannot remember all of them but I can
remember the last one that I played in
in Kolkata which gave me a lot of
confidence for my rapid and blitz skills
so yeah list that was the last one I'm
happy with
is magnus carlsen the man to beat in
destroy meat there in the whole year he
very best chances among among she's not
the one for me to beat for Maxine
it's different for the man to bait I
mean I'm not coming as a favorite but I
hope I had enough first and you know
that I'm gonna build on the fact that I
was not expecting to to be here at all
to to to make it work
Magnus Carlsen is a great a bit
everywhere and it's something that gives
everybody motivation here's this
I mean person that you want to mimic and
[Music]
occasionally be better I would generally
think so yeah